make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting back into our
video series on King Thor and I am very
excited about this I love the first
issue right the return of gorg it took
everything every ounce of strength I had
not to just like clickbait the title and
just be like the return of gorg like it
was everything I could everything I
could do not to do that we're not gonna
spoil the other fact that Gor returns
but now we're in the thick of it and we
get to see Gor face off against King
Thor and old man Loki and this is
amazing because here's a funny thing
about this as soon as score shows up
Thor freaks now for those of you guys
who saw our videos or read the story
Thor god of thunder by Jason Aaron right
the initial run of his I guess the
initial story with his run on Thor
it makes sense because gore the god
butcher was no small villain right like
this guy was was hard core this guy was
this guy was intense and it took Thor
from three different eras to defeat him
all of them working together to win and
then ultimately ended up taking a
modern-day Thor with the all-black necro
sword of Nullah symbiote God wielding
two hammers to basically went like it
was it was insane right it was no small
thing to beat this guy so to see that
he's back really begins to send Thor
into a frenzy because now is just kinda
like okay what in the heck do we do next
now here's the cool thing about gourd
this is one of the things I love the
most about I think it's one of the
things that most people love the most
about the way the gore was written the
gore was not your villain of the week
gore was dynamic he was basically this
guy where it was it was like he had a
family and he lived in a really harsh
world and like his tribe would pray to
the gods the gods never answer and so
ultimately he turned his back on the
gods he was exiled from his tribe
because of that and ultimately you know
of course he lost his wife and child
which is why he turned his back on them
in the first place and then in turn like
two gods fell from the sky and he
realized that gods were real but the
gods had basically been ignoring them so
he went on this campaign across the
entirety of the universe to kill every
God he found and it was it was it was
cool to see because when you took that
it made it very human insofar as those
of us who were in situations where it's
like why can't I just get one ounce of
help from someone somewhere I don't even
care what it is just will someone out
there help me right like we've all been
in that desperate situation that comes
from a variety of different
circumstances and so as a result of that
gore was kind of like that frustration
that we have with our life given form in
comic book and we loved it here's the
thing I wanna know what you're all
stances about I don't know what you're
all stance is on this gore the god
butcher I think he's the best Thor
villain there's ever been if I'm being
honest with you guys I think
or the god butcher is the best Thor
villain ever made right because he
taunts Thor here you know like Thor's
like I thought you were dead in Gore's
like wasn't I though I guess I guess I
really was but your brother Loki brought
me back when he brought back the
all-black necro sword
I came with it I've been in that sword
the entire time now on the surface it'd
be easy to kind of look at that and say
okay so this is basically just Jason
arrant pulling Thor out of it or pulling
Gore out of his backside because you
know whatever reason no no no no
remember the gore had used the all-black
necro sort for ages for eons and eons
and eons like he existed thousands of
years ago and his existed this entire
time running all the way up into the
future and I mean he'd existed really
almost to the end of time not really
quite to that point but pretty close to
that point right so you're talking about
a guy who's wielded a weapon not really
like a magical artifact for thousands of
years now in truth the all-black necro
sword was originally created by Nova
symbiote god but gore the god butcher
got his hands on it and learned all the
properties of it and so kind of bonding
himself to the all-black he was quite
literally it will distort himself within
the sword so that when the time came
when the sword was brought back he'd be
able to return as well but the funny
thing is that the statement made by Loki
is you know here like take this take
this artifact you know take this piece
of the all black and finish your work
and that's when Thor believes he begins
to pick up on what's going on there more
or less the summoning the resurrection
of gore of course did come by Loki but
it was believed or at least Thor
believes that Loki did this because Gore
would be able to kill for that
ultimately Thor believed that Loki
wouldn't wouldn't be able to do it on
his own right is the one thing you
wouldn't be able to do no matter what he
says no matter what no matter what he's
done it's always like one day I'm gonna
kill Fork but when the time comes you
wouldn't actually be able to do it and
so summoning gore would be the means by
which that could be done more so than
that and this is something to understand
here Loki has never met Gore so because
that Loki doesn't really know what gorg
is about in the mind of Loki is hey I
summoned you here to do a job get to a
man and in the response to Thor is know
Loki's job or I'm sorry Gore's job is
like kill gods everywhere he finds them
right you are a god Loki
he's going to kill you and that's
exactly what happens literally gorgeous
strings them both up and basically says
like I'm gonna kill both of you now and
it's kind of a cool thing because again
he spends the whole time taunting Thor
and that's what made gore so awesome the
fact that he would taunt Thor it wasn't
enough to say like I'm more powerful
than you so I'm going to kill you it had
to be one of these things up you believe
you're special because you're a god but
ultimately you're not
me show you how unspecial you are and
it's one of these cool things because
what he says is like let's see what's
inside let's see what kind of person you
are on the inside and of course thora
basically uses a Thor Force to blast war
into into the atmosphere I like to
blossom into orbit but what that does is
it leads to Thor trying to talk to Loki
and look it really kind of seems to be
at the point now where just like
whatever man like none of this really
matters right I mean for summonses
hammer he basically brings mule near in
which is kind of the battle everything
beginning to ramp up and that's what he
basically says fine if you're not gonna
be a part of this conflict if you're not
gonna help me defeat Gork then like I'll
do it on my own now understand this and
this is this is a very important thing
to understand that while Jason Aaron
depicts Thor in this way while Thor is
in this this mode where it looks like
he's got it under control and he's
contained on the inside he's panicking
right because it's Gork
it's Gore the god butcher and so not
only does this Thor summon earlier to
his side he also summons the the Odin
now of course the odinsword is it is is
a wildly powerful artifact and it
debuted back in journey into mystery
issue number 117 its origin is kind of
murky but the overall gist of this sword
is that when it's drawn that basically
all things will start to come to an end
right between the power possesses the
purpose for its wielding what this means
is this is an act of desperation Thor
grabbing this sword is basically a
scenario whereby it's kind of like it's
all or nothing and it does kind of make
sense because it's a battle for the ages
right it isn't a battle kind of near the
end of time is really with us where this
whole conflict is the death of the gods
so on and so forth and so with that
being the case what you also end up
learning is that while the all-black
necro sword was the primary weapon of
Gore the god butcher that in his time in
his exile more or less his isolation
what he's also been doing is fashioning
his own weapon which is called D an Ilah
blade is basically the planet cleaver
it's insane it's this massively colossal
sword it's probably the biggest weapon
that I think I've ever seen it's bonkers
how huge it is and this thing lives up
to its reputation this sword was
powerful if as it's shown here it's
powerful enough to plunge through a
planet and destroy it right so like it's
a pretty significant thing there's
something else to notice here is that
during this fight with the planet
cleaver being wielded by by gore and
with the odinsword and muller being
wielded by fork notice the way in which
Gore talks is
something that kind of caught me off
guard right what he says here are things
like I'm going to annihilate whatever
gods are left if there are any left of
course I'm going to kill them but then
I'm also going to refashion and recreate
everything like whatever humans are left
on earth I'm going to wipe them all out
and I'm going to create life anew it
almost seems kind of out of character
for Gore right because when you look at
Gore in terms of the context of Thor the
God of Thunder storyline for the most
part it was only one facet it was really
like one sequence of events that that
was going on with for he was a singular
act it was Gore's a guy who hates gods
gore has been killing gods
Gort devised this scheme to basically
create a bomb that could wipe out all
gods across the time line like that was
it it was the one plan that Gore had at
the time but the reality was despite all
the cool things that we saw about him we
didn't really get a full-on depiction of
everything that made gore who he was and
so where it does kind of seem to come
out of left field of well Jason Aaron's
making him this guy we just wants to
destroy the universe and recreated and
so on and so forth and it seems very
cliche that's not really the case the
funny thing about this is this falls
perfectly in line with the mecha nations
and the motivations of Gore Gore
despises gods Gore's wants to get rid of
God when Gore looks at various beings
out there who pray to gods he basically
says they do that because they don't
know any better
any being out there that lives their
whole life without ever having learned
to hate a god simply just didn't live
long enough the gods hadn't betrayed
them at that point but given enough time
they would it's the nature of gods it's
what they do it's so because Gore
maintained that ideology in his mind
looking at the various dit isms on earth
those individuals who eventually kind of
been brought back or at least you know
earth kind of thriving the way it is
since the end of Thor god of thunder
when new all-father thor kind of brought
back life on earth when he looks at that
and says like all these beings are
praying to Thor's because they don't
know any better
so I will wipe them clean I will
basically sterilize this planet and I
will I will leave the universe into a
place whereby it doesn't believe in
God's where there's no reason to believe
in a God at all because all they do is
betray things and this is where Loki
makes his move right when Loki's been
strung up up to this point and the
various denizens really kind of show up
here and then ultimately end up freeing
him this is one of the coolest moments
because where you have gore the god what
you're going on these these grandiose
speeches gods are bad I'm gonna destroy
gods I'm the God butcher so on and so
forth Loki shows up it's just kind of
like you amuse me right like I was
butchering gods
long before you were ever born right
like I am the original God butcher so
when you come here and you start
talking about the fact that you're the
god butcher and you're gonna start doing
these things on and so forth understand
you're a half-measure in comparison to
me and this is where Loki's like
misunderstanding of the situation comes
into play because as epic as it is loki
has never met gore like he's never met
this guy before it he doesn't understand
what he's getting into
right off the bat gore helps low key
understand his place in the bigger
picture what he slices his arm off
after that he interned blinds he
eventually like like takes his eyes out
and it's like Loki like like you've seen
so much but at the end of the day you're
never gonna see anything else like in
the span of seconds the tide has turned
and this is the kind of power that
you're talking about here when it comes
to court because even Loki despite the
fact that he's not really Asgardian that
he's more he's essentially frost giant
he's still a force to be reckoned with
understand that like Loki against most
superheroes on earth like 99% of the
superheroes on earth it's no contest
because of all this power he possesses
when someone like gore comes along and
takes him out that fast that says
something it says something about the
kind of power that Gore has and it's one
of the reasons why we loved the original
god of thunder so much because it was
just this guy who showed up seemingly
out of nowhere and wrecked these guys
and so what you end up getting is this
Thor really trying to reach out to Loki
and say like come on like you have to
help me out here the way this whole
thing played out is that yes Loki did
summon gore that's true but the idea
behind this was that Loki wouldn't be
able to take himself out that Loki
really wanted to eliminate Thor and then
basically die himself but Loki wouldn't
be able to have to have taken himself
out in that way and so the idea was to
summon gore to bring him here
so that Gore would kill for and then
kill Loki and then kind of go forward
from there but Loki miscalculated in the
extreme because Gore is not like anybody
he's ever met before and so as a result
of that you basically have Loki who and
these these last moments really sort of
begin to kind of focus on what it was a
Thor had told him like that like their
mother Frigga kind of been like she was
disappointed in you she she was totally
let down by you you were failure in
every conceivable way where Thor had
basically lied about that in order to
kind of demoralize Loki so he could
essentially defeat him that he comes out
with the truth and says I've been lying
as well our mother loved you our mother
loved you more than anything and her
dying words to me were do not let your
brother go
and that's why Thor has been holding on
to Loki for so long right it's why he
doesn't let Loki die it's why he doesn't
work alongside were to kill Loki or
something like that but why he hasn't
killed Loki himself is because he knows
Loki was loved by his mother and at the
end
day despite Loki's mechanisms and
schemes he's the brother of Ford and so
what you end up getting is in these
final moments here when they're all when
they're consumed by the aw block you
have Thor reaching out for Loki and you
have Loki who seems to reach out for
Thor and before we find out what happens
this story ends madness this is
fantastic
like I absolutely adore this story I
love Jason Aaron's work right like Jason
Aaron has the best run on Thor that I
think there's ever been but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here two
comments explain it make sure you guys
to the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]